[Music]
this year's film independent spirit
award nominees for best editing
[Music]
the winner is chloe jowl for nomad land
i'd like to share this award with our
entire
post-production team you guys are
incredible
um we edited this film doing the
lockdown everyone was so hard working
passionate and flexible and very
innovative
finding ways to tell stories together
when we couldn't be together
so this award belongs to you guys the
nominees for best international film
the winner is coabadis aida thank you to
film independent for supporting this
film
thank you producers wonderful actors
thank you all amazing team who made this
film
with lots of love in true independent
spirit
the nominees for best cinematography
winner is joshua james richards for
nomad land
what a team we had on this film um thank
you to our producers peter spears
molly asha dan jamvi and then stoppable
francis mcdormand
and finally i owe all of this to our
courageous and and beautiful uh director
chloe jowl chloe thank you for putting
up with me
um onward let's never look back
the john cassavetes award nominees
the winner is residue this is an
incredible honor um
i'm so happy to accept it on behalf of
the entire reza crew
you know people who really came out of
nowhere and just put it all on the line
to make this film happen
and the nominees for best new
non-scripted or documentary series
[Music]
the spirit award goes to immigration
nation
thank you for this honor and thank you
to everyone that has helped this project
come to fruition
impact partners chicago media project
our entire edit
production and post-production team and
netflix for believing in our vision
to the men and women of ice and to the
immigrant characters
we are so grateful that you trusted us
with this story
thank you so much for this award we are
truly truly humbled